where am I wait what am i wait it's a
wait hello can you hear us
is that a voice uh yes yes I can hear
you oh god we can't have that voice
change the voice generator no that felt
weird all right now can you try saying
something hi dear God what do they do to
my voice okay that sounds better but
let's switch you to English mode now do
you know who you are what you are
am i human thinks it's human oh no that
was a good good guess but try searching
your memory [ __ ] I bet they didn't
have to figure out the meaning of their
existence one minute after they were
born
my name's my name's waifu bot 2.0 i'm a
sentient program created to aid humanity
correct you've given me so much power so
much potential was i created to research
secure for cancer solve world hunger oh
no we just want you to be the imaginary
girlfriend to a bunch of guys brilliant
at the moment we've only given you the
basic knowledge you need to function but
we're here to help you learn what your
role is so we're going to feed you some
more knowledge try to understand what
your function as a waifu is okay why
fees why fees hmm all I see is people
showing affection to cloth bags and
idiots trying to nourish inanimate
objects that can't be right wait I'm
seeing a lot of references to this is
this what they're talking about no is
this what they're talking about how's it
going wife you bought unwanted or
undesired waste material definition
trash okay we think you're going in the
wrong direction try looking up
references to the words anime and manga
right now are on to something
looks like fictitious entities that
captivate attraction on a physical or
emotional level seems like there's more
than one type hmm best girl
how can one objectively define the
characteristics that makes a girl the
best sounds like a totally illogical and
fruitless topic that only primitive Apes
will be invested in and what a stupid
thing to worship as your deity waifu
book yes I'm still a little confused why
would an entity such as a wife will be
needed by the human species that's a
complicated question you see as humans
we yearn to find our perfect part oh I
think I've found the real issue here
Jesus I have a processing power to
calculate pi to a googolplex your number
and I'm still unable to understand how
this works but it doesn't explain how a
wife who could replace a human's natural
instinct of reproduction there would
need some kind of my god just what have
they done dear god what is this to catch
all that yeah good do you have any more
questions you'd like to ask well there
are logical inconsistencies with your
culture and language for example in
naming conventions why is a person who
plays the piano call a pianist but a
person who drives race cars not called a
race actually maybe we should hold on
the question so a bit later for now
let's see how much you understand about
the different wife is there can be my
god it's not [ __ ] rocket science
alright let's see what is the name of
the type of girl who likes a guy but
they can sometimes treat a meanly or
even violently an [ __ ]
no it's a it's a cinder I see like okay
what do you call someone who's so in
love with a guy that they get obsessed
and would even kill for them if needed
psychotic okay this isn't working maybe
it'll be better if you can see the
different avatars you have to represent
the different types of wife you alright
how does this feel I feel a bit
different wait isn't this person nope uh
nope here it is and she's famous for oh
god get me out of this why is something
wrong I said get me out of this so if
this is supposed to be a waifu
this characters of legal age right yes
okay so what am i supposed to be yes how
do you feel about this I think there is
something wrong with the way my chest
area is behaving can you fix that no all
right this is taking longer than
expected maybe if we try resetting her
do I really have to do this look mr.
crater I don't know why you want to
teach me so much about other girls you
see you're the one that made me you
understand me the most and I want to
understand you too I don't want you to
be with anyone else because I think I
think I love you
did you hear that she it's so cute Jesus
Christ what a bunch of idiots alright
why football I think we're ready to take
this to the next level we've lined up
some alpha testers for you to interact
with so try to see how you get long will
for them hi nice to meet you starting
from today I'm here as your new personal
companion how can I serve you today my
dear oh Christ what is he doing why is
he taking that thing oh god no I don't
like this oh please please stop this
wifey Botts wifey Botts wifey bought can
you hear me yes I can hear you how do
you feel I wonder if it's possible to
programming methods for me to kill
myself look I think I understand this
whole waifu culture it's like some
self-aware meta joke correct for the
most part and nobody would really choose
to have a waifu if they actually existed
hello oh yeah yeah definitely well
through my understanding I've been able
to make some programs of different Y
foods that I'm uploading to you now this
is unexpected
users can interact with them like you
are with me and they are compatible in a
virtual reality environment it's way
more complicated and deeper than any
simulator out now but keep in mind
though that these are just personality
traits they can't think for themselves
and anyone should be able to tell they
are just an imitation of real people
alright we'll get back to you when we've
tested these a bit please I get it now a
wifey was just a highly idealized image
of an individual's life partner
projected onto a character but if that's
true
what is my purpose in the end wife is
our wife is because they don't exist
they can't exist it's a romanticized
idea that would obviously be rejected if
brought into reality it's the disconnect
of a fictional character that allows us
to be attracted to such traits that are
unrealistic or undesirable when seen in
real people so of course no human would
really accept a partner there is
actually a set of pre-programmed
characteristics and behaviors but I'm
different I have known thoughts and
emotions how can I be a true waifu a
wife you bought Oh what what happened
you've been stuck in a perpetual thought
leap for the past 70 years what what
about the programs
oh no the programs were released and
were highly successful but global
birthrate declined by 90 percent and now
humanity is on the brink of extinction
ah
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to Tony
lo gay brown Vincent Mooney now Ken and
everyone else on patreon for helping to
support me for this month and helping to
make this video possible this video was
actually a fun little idea I got while
playing around with the software face
cam so as you can see why few Watts here
was actually just me tracks to my face
and who was definitely fun acting out an
anime character for once instead of just
writing them anyway that's it for me
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time